coming to the workshop we do have a last
workshop too and in just three weeks
actually two and a half weeks so our
final speaker is our teasing from CMU
thanks to all the organizers actually
for enjoying organizing the workshops I
have really enjoyed both the first one
and the second one more on the learning
side I guess then on yeah
contributing side but still it's it's
been great and oh yeah thank you all for
staying til the last talk I was
imagining I'd be giving this talk
outside with people you know having food
and drinks because it was listened to me
at the same time as the break so I
thought it would be maybe that's the
closing but unfortunately are back here
so okay let's let's talk about yeah an
aspect that has been briefly mentioned
in this workshop there were a few talks
talking about it but maybe I'll say a
little bit more about our work in this
direction on convolutional and recurrent
neural networks okay and I wanted to
highlight the students who were part of
this project
hearing Wang and Simon two are both my
students or were my students they
graduated recently and have moved on to
do great things and Jo is at MIT
actually who is collaborating with them
and then two of my colleagues Sivir and
Russ who are also part of the
discussions we've had on this so this
work is actually so 2018 kind of based
on a paper that appears at New York's 18
and I know you saw Hani's talk on Monday
which was all like May 20 19 stuff but
I'll make connections to that and talk
about new actually things that are on
the archive the number is 18 but
actually we've updated a very recently
to include some of the recurrent neural
network results so yeah hopefully
there's yeah okay so yeah again I mean I
don't have to motivate this too much but
a large part of the success has been in
deep networks using convolutional neural
networks right so this is I think the
picture from the latest version of image
net this
20:17 and all of the networks that you
see that were able to drive the accuracy
all the way down to this 99 point
whatever percent they're all correlation
neural networks or variations thereof or
building on including the last one SC
nuts is also based on CMS but despite
that theory has not addressed the
convolutional neural networks as much
and if you think about yeah what
convolutional neural networks are really
doing they're exploiting some spatial
structure in your data right so the
network architecture encodes some
spatial assumptions essentially about
what your data might look like and we
can talk about apart from spatial if you
think about temporal dimension or some
sequential dimension then a recurrent
neural networks come to mind which do
the same thing where they encode
temporal dependencies instead of spatial
dependencies so what we did for cnn's we
were able to apply it to the recurrent
neural network architecture we'll be
focusing actually my talk will be on
very simple models for these that are
introduced though you could think about
then extensions of those two more
nonlinear even things like LS theorems
which are nowadays much more popular
than or announced right but yeah just to
say that
so just to again bring home the point
fully connected networks they start with
some high dimensional input and every
layer subsequent layer every node is a
layer is connected to all the nodes in
the previous layer so it's a fully
connected network throughout and has
lots of parameters to two convolutional
neural networks start by saying that
there is instead a convolutional filter
that will be applying two parts of the
input so that in every subsequent layer
a particular node only depends on a
subset of their input nodes it's that's
where the convolution structure comes in
it's like a local spatially local
structure that's been built in and it's
followed sometimes by different pooling
layers subsampling max pooling are is
pulling different forms of it and again
repetitions of convolution sense of
sampling so it's saving on the number of
parameters that are being used to map
the input to the output
and recurrent neural network
do the same thing except with sequential
data where this is your input now throw
it over there then put us here and it's
divided into segments so this could be a
text document and these are the
different words in it or again you can
think of any kind of sequential data and
they are actually mapped to every
segment is mapped to a lower dimensional
space so originally the segment could be
part of a very high dimensional sailor
your features being the entire
vocabulary so a very high dimensional
space but they are mapped to a low
dimensional space here in space and
there's an evolution that's governing
the hidden equation or hidden States and
finally you predict the output or label
of that and this is just to set up the
the architecture that we'll be
considering a little bit more concretely
and we will actually be talking about a
setting where we assume generative
models for these three settings so more
specifically we will be considering that
our label by eye is generated according
to a model one of these models plus
noise where noise will have some
standard properties that I talked about
your input is going to be d dimensional
and all the inputs are sampled iid from
some distribution and again the
assumptions will come later on what we
more assumptions we make about these but
we are in this sort of realized they
were the setting so I'm going to tell
you that if I believe my data was
actually generated from a convolutional
neural network model then how well can
we learn its parameters okay so we are
sort of going to be in this realized it
was sudden and will consider some simple
architectures so for convolutional
neural networks we'll look at two
versions one is with a two layer Network
where okay this is what the network will
look like you have your input you have a
convolution filter W acting on the input
in the firstly this is the one hidden
layer and then there is going to be an
output layer which is just an average
pooling layer so it's just going to take
to an average of although I know it's in
the hidden layer to come up with the
output so that's CNN with average
pooling yeah this is just rewriting it
again so this is just your segments of
the
but and this is the convolution filter
being applied to that and then the
average pooling happening adulthood so I
guess just to highlight some parameters
that will be of interest the size of the
filter which is just this vector W its
length and the stride of the filter is
how much does this filter move by when
I'm applying it to the input so if if my
s stride is equal to M then it's a
completely non overlapping case so
you're moving the filter in overlapping
manner otherwise it's going to be
overlapping
so in general s is going to be between 1
and M and with bated pooling will again
have a 2 layer architecture but in this
case will allow the output layer to just
form we also train that essentially so
it will have some set of weights called
a qualified business a vector and they
are going to form a weighted combination
of your so just to point out in this
case the size of the output layer is
going to be D is my input D dimensional
M is the filter that's moving on it so
if I just do D minus M / S which is the
stride how much I move by that's going
to tell me about the size of the output
layer is so I'll use J to indicate that
so just we clear it is not linear it is
exactly
so very very simple starting just one
hidden layer one output layer everything
is linear and it's realizable say of a
simpler setting possible essentially and
yeah we'll talk about this awesome I
guess huh nice talk on Monday for
example was for CNN so where you could
talk about nonlinear activations and so
on and we'll talk about the differences
so let me also set up the model for our
MN so for recurrent neural networks we
consider a similar model it's going to
be a linear model where the output again
Y is generated from RN n which is given
by just the sum so you can think of this
as the average pooling layer in the
previous case this is just doing an
average pooling on the final hidden
statement
and the segment's the hidden segments
evolve according to a linear model again
it's just a linear dynamical system a
very simple setting of starting with the
initial hidden state of zero so here
again to remind us of some parameters a
is going to be which is the mapping
between the hidden states so it's our
dimensional hidden state so a is R by R
and this B which is taking every new
segment to account will be R by D matrix
so essentially the idea is that D is the
dimension of our input in the case of
convolution neural networks we are going
to somehow say that that doesn't matter
all that matters is the filter size
which is M in this case similarly D is
the dimension of the end or actually D
is the dimension of the input but L is
the length which is what is the
important part so I will say that there
are L segments right which is the length
of the input and that's not what's going
to be the important part the R which is
the hidden dimensions that V naught 2 is
what will show up in our bounds so maybe
let me before I talk about ya more
detail about the bounds let me say a
little bit more that one the model may
not be identifiable right so we are not
making any norm constraints on these or
any other constraints on the weight
parameters so you could of course take
the W and the a and move constants
between them similarly in the RNN case
you can interchange some of the hidden
units and the model in that case is not
identifiable but we would not care about
that because we focus on the mean square
prediction error so instead of recovery
of the parameters you are just going to
talk about prediction performance so our
error will be measured as just the mean
square error where theta hat is our
estimated parameters there are the two
parameters and we'll be looking at how
well we do under this mean square
and will be an inner minimax setup where
our goal is to upper and lower bound the
minimax risk which is the expectation of
this error taking the soup over that
over all possible parameters that we are
allowing in our models and the info bar
any estimator so what's estimator will
consider actually the simplest possible
estimator which is least squares so like
let's just fix fix the outer one you
want to maximize the error
this is estimators theta hat is the
estimator you know minimize the error by
choosing a good estimator that works
well for any theta this is the standard
minimax setup so you are saying that I
am defining a class of models in my case
the models are given by CNN RR and then
I'm committing to that and saying that
for any parameter vector that is of that
form the CNN odds are M in model form I
want to come up with a good estimator
that
so here's a particular Terra hat will be
generating that works well for any of
those that's it's just a classical
minimax it okay so the specific
estimator will consider is the least
squares estimator so we are just going
to say that we have got a minimize over
theta this least square performance on
our training data and of course this may
not be unique so our guarantees will
apply to any global minimizer we are
also going to ignore the computational
considerations so we are not saying how
you find this global minimizer but it's
a squared loss so it is it's yeah we
don't have to worry about suboptimal
minimizer's okay so they are all good
and our guarantees will apply to any
global miser that you find in the common
situations okay
so beyond this this is what the
framework we also need two assumptions
the first one is sort of mild which is
just saying that the noise is your
standard sub Gaussian noise independent
and so on the second one is what yeah
many of you may not agree with but I'll
talk about the importance of it and how
we might be able to relax it later so
here we assume that the input
distribution so this is what the X eyes
are drawn from is a centered sub
Gaussian and it has this covariance
structure which has lower and upper
bounded by n values function is between
C identity yeah this is fairly strong
but it's saying we are essentially
exciting all the directions and our
input and again I will mention the exact
place where we need it it's it's crucial
but yeah it means that it's unimodal the
margin is Uni more than yes yes consider
assumptions like situations like you
know like where you can do
they say me supervised learning because
the different types of examples so
you're not going to any complicated
thing here the goal is just to say CN n
an RN and what governs their sample
complexity is it the ampion dimension or
the ambient input or ambient yeah input
sequence length in the case of RN n or
is it the structure the simplified
structure that these models encode all
right so I'll present first the informal
result and then show you the more exact
mathematical forms but the informal
results sales that CN n with average
pooling the first model its minimax rate
is just M by n where m is the size of
the filter and is the number of samples
so the significance of this is again
that it's independent of the input
dimension the input features x i's have
dimension D so you may would otherwise
if we didn't have this particular
structure the convolution structure will
expect a d by n right so this is similar
to the toggle Monday
oh honey stock except oh yeah the rates
are a little bit I talked about the
difference with weighted pooling we get
something similar where we now get a m +
j / n where m is the size of the filter
and j is essentially the size of the
second output layer so because we are
training both of those the convolution
filter and the first hidden layer as
well as the output layer so you just get
M plus G over N for our n similarly we
get the dimension of the input times the
hidden given state length okay you don't
get the length of the input sequence or
what you get already over n so again
here it's independent of the sequence
length and all right if you just did the
analysis you thought about a fee I have
L segments each D dimensional you would
expect a rate of LD over a number we
primitive it is exactly the yeah that's
what I've done in the next
and the number of samples so yeah in
other way two interpreters is how many
samples you need you can say to achieve
an error epsilon you need already over
and yeah exactly as somebody pointed out
this matches the parameter count
intuition that here we are only training
this one single filter which is M
dimensional so we get M by n here we are
doing both the convolution filter and
the output filter so exactly the note
that M plus J comes in which is the size
of the output filter
similarly for our ml we are training A's
and the B's which are R square plus Rd
dimensional so it's ordered already
because R is of course much smaller than
V so that's what we get so it's just a
it matches with the parameter count
I'll say a little bit about connection
to related work first so of course there
have been many attempts at proving
generalization bounds for neural
networks you have seen several of those
here in this workshop as well and some
of them apply to CNN's like the one on
Monday's talk and again I have not
listed probably have miss many many
references but a lot of these
generalization bounds they do not make
the assumption some of the assumptions
that I've mentioned so far but they are
of this form they show that your
generalization error is like the
training error plus essentially is a
model complexity D over root N and our
bounds are different in that one there
faster rates we actually show 1 by n
rates instead of 1 by root n rates of
course these occur under some
assumptions and also the model
complexity typically depends on the size
of the parameters whereas our bounds are
actually independent of those they have
no dependence on the magnitude of your
parameters and these phenomena are
actually not new they come up in high
dimensional or over parameterize
problems all the time
in fact for lasso right the standard
high dimensional linear regression setup
these issues are lost over any sparsity
based analysis these issues come up also
it's just Sigma square whatever is this
important parameter it's linear in that
right that's similar to dependence on
the size of the quality
so typically here either dependence on
both you get Sigma squared times the
norm of the weight we don't have the
norm of the weight in there so I guess
there are two models you can consider
one is an agnostic setting where I still
have a noise and I characterize the
noise but I say that my model may not
commit to be no CNN or nrmn model in
that case is what I'm saying that's
where these the D would still have Sigma
square times norm of weight so yeah even
over those agnostic in the sense of
being immortal is agnostic but you still
have additive noise ratio big and small
team yes that comes up and it's that's a
little bit more complicated it's usually
the ratio except I think one place where
we get the C Big C square over little C
but I think that can probably be done is
in the least squares case the minimax
ruses we are using the V squared
I mean like yeah in the least-squares
case we would depend on that finger I'm
assuming that to translate between them
because that thing also gives up the
know what the weights would be since
we're doing the least-squares estimator
at least where's estimator will depend
on them okay so yeah let me quickly
mention that even in the RN setting
actually this model is just a special
case of the classical linear dynamical
systems on which there is a lot of work
and in fact I have not mentioned the
older results there are recent results
also that look at the problem both from
statistical and computational
perspectives but their sample
complexities are not tied at least with
stuff so let me mention the formal upper
bounds and then I'll give some intuition
into why these bounds hold this way and
what are the assumptions that go in and
why they are important so the forward
bound is as follows it says with high
probability for sufficiently large n how
large that n needs to be is just enough
to make sure this is less than 1 all the
bonds are less than the one essentially
right or decreasing is what I mean
oh one then we have the falling bounce
so for the two layer only training the
hidden layer part you just get Sigma
squared M log B over n so long these the
only dimension dependence that comes in
it's there in the upper bound not there
in the lower bound for the one way we
are also training the output layer you
get this expression which actually
reduces to the parameter counting
expression M plus j jb in the output
layer and notice that J is just D over s
right you're taking out in D dimensional
input and moving the stride s over it so
it's sort of chunking it up into D bias
pieces so that's where the output
dimension comes in so that's this term
we do have an extra term this M / S
which we conjecture can actually be
removed so there should not be this
extra stride dependence but it's coming
in and again I'm happy to talk offline
about like why it shows up in our upper
bound it's not there in the lower bound
but when at least when we assume that
the stride is the same size or is the
same order as
filter sites in that case this just
reduces to a parameter counting argument
and similarly for recurrent neural
networks we have something which looks
like this but in classical settings this
is just a parameter counting argument Rd
because of course the hidden state
dimension is much less than the ambient
dimension but also your sequence length
right so the length of a document is
typically less than the vocabulary
dimension so under again under these
wild assumptions this does give you the
parameter accounting arguments the
higher-level stepping like vanishing or
exploding gradients form and your bonds
are independent of a sequence length so
there's a magic algorithm that avoids
this somehow and find speed
yes and that's true I but I'm not sure
you're pointing to that if we take the
optimization into account as well then
you will get a dependence on that's not
the focus exactly this is just sample
complexity in ignoring computational
issues
okay so yeah let me give you some idea
of like where some of these things come
in what's just to give a proof sketch
and why some of the assumptions are
important so for least squares solution
we just know it's minimizing the squared
loss so that's where the first term is
and if because you've assumed the
generative model so if I plug in Y I is
actually equal to that X I comma theta
plus Epsilon and massage this bound it
essentially implies this upper bound on
how far our estimate is from the true
estimate in a norm that's defined by the
data so this is just the norm there we
are looking at T at minus theta
transpose X transpose X theta at minus
theta
under that norm you you get this upper
bound and again it turns out if you want
to get the regular 1 over root n rate
everything is much easier you actually
don't have to go through this particular
step you can just upper bound your
parameters are bounded lot of other
things get bounded and you can do the
covering number argument very easily but
if you want to get to the fast rates
then you actually have to look at what
is called the self normalized empirical
process kind of direction of proof where
essentially yeah if I take this
expression and again just massage it
around a little bit you can show that
it's equivalent to the norm bound
without the square and this term which
is essentially an empirical process
epsilon is some sub Gaussian noise this
is a vector that's you are taking an
error out with that this is an empirical
process and we are taking the soup of
that empirical process where because I
removed one of the squares and I have
essentially have to do this search only
over vectors whose now about norm is
bounded by one so this is actually the
critical part which requires us to which
gives us the fast rate but also requires
us to make some assumptions because now
of course what we want to do is you can
use this technique called at least
integral which essentially says you can
upper bound this self normalize
empirical process in terms of the
covering number the only issue is the
covering number is for this set which
has a non constraint on fee but it's in
terms of the data so we have to convert
this for
but we can compute is a covering number
when you have a constraint on the tune
on not on something that depends on the
data this is much harder to the covering
number for this side is much harder so
we need a way to relate this to this and
that's where our assumption of saying
it's almost isotropic comes in and
actually the assumption comes in you'll
again see very a lot of dependence to
what happens in high dimensional
pressure it comes in through the use of
restricted eigenvalues so just like in
high dimensional linear regression like
law so kind of analysis we require
assumption talking about how eigen
values look like on restricted subspace
here also we are talking about
essentially this is just as I said fie
transpose X transpose X fee divided by
norm V transpose V so we are just
defining this eigenvalue and but we are
restricting it instead of just taking
the info or any fee we are taking the
gain for fee in this set so that's yeah
so we need to define this restricted
eigen values which help us translate a
covering number argument on the
empirical norm bound it vectors to the
and there are papers again you can des
and analysis you can also go do it with
local rather complexity but they
directly make assumptions on this
without making the isotropic kind of
assumptions we night so you do need that
assumption if you want to get these type
of so let's maybe I'll mention one key
ingredient without going through the
details so I said I won't take that much
time so one other key argument is that
the covering number bounds and actually
this is probably the most important
though a technical technical
straightforward part which is that the
covering number bounds because we need
to be applied to low dimensional
subspaces because when we are moving
this filter around you are essentially
talking about things getting mapped to a
lower dimension or in the case of RN and
also to the hidden state so we have this
covering number bound which tells you
how to do this bound when you have a
union of linear subspaces how you can
bound that so I'll just mention this and
time I can talk later about how you use
this bound to come up it's life
the covering number argument but that's
essentially what's needed so what are
the lower ones look like they here are
lower bounce it says that if the input
and the noise distribution are standard
normal and again having lower bounds for
that setting does not those roller
bounds apply to any distributional
settings right there exists a universal
constant such that we basically get
these rates that I talked about which
are essentially the parameter counting
arguments in each case reminding again
that the output here is D bias
I won't go with the proof sketch for the
lower bound it's based on the finals
llama and again is so let me show you
some experiments so first is for the
average pulling case so this is
initially the stride means set equal to
M so it's the non-overlapping setting
but what we can see is in this case the
error was M by n so we see the error
clearly decreases with N and it
increases with M so M is increasing
between these figures and the error of
the red curve which is the CNN is
increasing the FN and of course the
fully connected network is and if you
change the stripe size so here this ride
is only 1 so this is the other extreme
the plots are exactly the same so there
is clearly no dependence on the stride
at least in this set so we verify the
theoretical results and by n with no
dependence on the stride for the second
case we do get our dependence on this
well so the way the dependence on the
stride comes in is through J the larger
the stripe the lower is the outputs size
and so you see that as the size
increases we get this so so the hidden
the network is yeah is a CNN and we
generated according to that but the
parameters of the CNN are generated
randomly yes yes yeah we just used a
innocent in this case
what and then for our and also it's the
same thing you can verify the are at
least the are over N rate so with
increasing hidden units there're
increases but otherwise if you do them
so yeah let me conclude time is that
open questions are is this fast rate
possible without the generative model
assumptions and without distributional
assumptions the answer is yes in low
dimensions in high dimensions it's not
even known for Allah so actually or
problems of sparsity based problems so
again I think the answer may be yes if
we allow computationally inefficient
estimators for example in high
dimensional sparse D based analysis if
you allow root for search over the best
subset of coordinates to pick then you
would get the faster rates potentially
but at least with computationally
efficient estimators it's unclear
whether yeah we can achieve that without
making any distributional assumptions
restricted eigenvalue is needed for
analysis and of course extensions to
these some of these we'll talked about
in the first on the first day but they
were all for the slow rate and for the
faster rate again because of the Ceph
normalize process it is that's one route
to go these analysis are much harder but
they can potentially be done and then
yeah clearly role of optimization we
have in old but I just want to highlight
one thing that I think the similarities
to the sparse high dimensional linear
regression and how many parallels exist
between the two settings is very
interesting and suggests that any
progress in one dimension right we can
sort of borrow that progress over here
as well
so one wonderful minute a question the
pastor a person slow rates the results
we show cause the one over square in
right then could be accelerated for one
over n right if you use a strongly
convex last like a quadratic boss that
you use just because those results are
relying on balance of the wise and the
losses you're using something you're
worrying about the consequences of a
bound on those things given that the
bound you have is in the input space
which is you know we but the things I
think is striking really striking here
so I guess you know you you do this kind
of parameter County remedy County sort
of results they're corresponding things
for the recurrent case you know it
qualitatively looks rather similar when
you have nonlinearities but the big
difference is there that you get a
factor of the amount of computation the
number of steps that you're that you're
computing which you don't get in the
linear case do you have some intuition
about why it's so much when you say that
you had the computation you mean the
number of segments right yeah yeah so
yes it does show up in our bounds
though I guess I was arguing for the
settings so if I go back it is the L but
which again in the high level yeah it's
it is here but I guess I was arguing
that it's equal to the parameter
counting argument Rd if L is much less
than T so I was thinking of the settings
of like text where D is much higher
dimensional it's the vocabulary size and
L is the length of your document but it
does show up here I see so it's
multiplicative just like when you
if you just want to test it your effects
coming from its debris get across like
this just doing the testing can you do
it faster and that's something yeah we
haven't thought about but yeah it's it's
a good question I guess in simpler
settings like I mean you can ask the
question even in the linear setting or
something right
it's you're asking about testing for
sparsity level for example in high
dimensional problems and I don't know
what the results say there I know people
have looked at it it's just well are you
talking about like you're just saying
whether it's sparse or not a versus
actual what's the level of sparsity
there are different
GRU right I think that was first without
assumption some assumptions you can't
even do that actually
yeah so I mean I like it say in this
context of course no we haven't thought
about it and I don't think anybody has
but like in the context of some simple
as far as regression models you can ask
the same question and there some answers
are known but even those I don't think
anything is possible without taking
assumptions
you don't need at least all the work
that I know required to function